last year it was the chargers as the
second place team in the nfc west they
went 12 and four and made it to the
divisional round riding the ravens in
the wild card round this year second
place team
after five weeks
is the oakland raiders and you know i i
wrote them off early on they yes they
beat the broncos on that opening monday
night but lost by 18 at home to the
chiefs lost by 20 on the road to the
vikings i just figured that's it it's
done right it's just going to be a slow
disintegration they went to indianapolis
and beat the colts which to me is one of
the stunners of the season so far and
then to handle the bears in london
yesterday with all the travel
and they went to indianapolis and then
they went straight to london and they
would have been gone and they don't have
a home game until early november
but i got to give them credit
they they got to the uh 17 nothing lead
the bears took the lead 21-17 after
three yeah and then a 13-play 97-yard
drive against that chicago defense
down the field the raiders went to get
what became the game-winning points
24-21 victory and i think we have to
take them seriously well i i think
they're going to be a pain in the butt
you know am i am i sitting here right
now going oh the raiders i think are a
playoff team i'm still on the fence
about that type of conversation but i
think john gruden's done a great job of
knowing his team and how to manage his
team on a weekly basis for the right
game plan for to give them a chance to
win it's it's get the ball out of the
hand with derek carr you know high
percentage passes we're not going to
take too many chances in the passing
game in general we're going to run the
ball their defense i think has been one
of the surprises to me you know yeah you
know i know the chiefs won by 18 but it
was all in one quarter they kind of gave
them issues the other three quarters you
know i really look at the vikings game
the only game where they really got they
kind of got steamrolled by that run game
up there in minnesota but you had their
defense and then john gruden's ability
to continue to run the ball and having a
special running back and offensive line
that can move people that way
i certainly didn't expect them to move
the bears front seven the way they did
yesterday and it was that khalil mack
trade last year that put a dark cloud
over john gruden's first year back in
the nfl they went four and 12. and it
just felt like he was heading toward
disaster territory that the game had
passed him by that he wasn't able to
coach today's players the way that he
was able to effectively coach years ago
right but here they are three and two
yeah one win fewer than all of 2018
already bye week
yeah get a load of this right at the
packers right which gruden was an
assistant on that team in 92 that has
like 10 head coaches future head coaches
on it at the packers at the texans right
then a home game against the lions their
first home game in seven weeks chargers
on a short week after that
bengals at the jets and then at the
chiefs early december you know some
winnable games coming up yeah but the
first two games after the buy are going
to tell us a lot about
whether what we saw the last year yeah
they really legit right or whether they
are ready if they can come out of this
two-week opportunity to get ready for
the green bay packers stick it to aaron
rodgers and matt lafleur right and you
know green's gonna be feisty about that
we're going back to green bay where
where he once used to coach of course
it's
i
i love a good story yeah and the nfl is
always a better story when the raiders
are agreed i mean yes i i i
love the raiders franchise that it is
cool when they are good uh hey it's
always good to have john gruden back in
the game he's a great personality and a
great coach in the sport so
it's good to see that they've turned
this organization around after a very
tough training camp and things like that
and also on the flip side i mean the
bears are just disappointing i mean damn
the bear's offense stinks i don't know
what to say it just stinks they put
together one drive yesterday the whole
game and the raiders defense played
solid not trying to take anything away
from them but they're certainly not like
the steelers of the 70s
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports